the ERG chairman Mark Francois said
I'd like to thank
I'd like to thank the Star Chamber
chaired by sabil cash MP and ably
supported by Martin Howe Casey Barnabas
Reynolds and David Jones MP for their
diligent and thorough examination of the
legal implications of the Windsor
framework
the star Chambers principal findings are
that EU law will still be Supreme in
Northern Ireland the rights of its
people under the 1800 Act of Union are
not restored
the Green Lane is not really a Green
Lane at all
the Stormont break is practically
useless
and the framework itself has no exit
other than through a highly complex
legal process that is a very brief
summary of the findings of the style
chamber you should hopefully all have a
copy of the report with a press release
and there's a nice diagram on the back
that shows you how the storm won't break
in theory at least is meant to work I
hope that's a quick summary I can take
four or five quick questions so sorry
let's uh let's start here uh and about
five news yeah do you accept that as a
result of this if the government were to
follow your proposals there will be a
hard order
that's a logical conclusion projecting
no I don't accept that at all uh and and
the reasons why that is not correct are
set out in the report but I would
encourage you to read it so who's next
yes top will you be voting against the
proposals therefore and how many ERG
colleagues of yours do you expect will
follow suit right on that the dup have
made their position very plain they're
going to vote against we to some degree
have been critical of the government for
not allowing people enough time to
digest everything so for instance the
statutory instruments and the
explanatory notes only came out
yesterday
so we don't want to be hoist by our own
so we've just made this public now it is
available on the internet and the email
address at lawyers for Britain is on
your press release if you could
propagate that we would be grateful so
that other members of parliament can
read this this is by no means just for
the ERG we'd like all members of
parliament ideally to read this before
the vote tomorrow so they know exactly
what they're voting on and we'd like
members of the public and particularly
people in Northern Ireland to have an
opportunity to read this report so that
they understand what is at stake
because we need to allow people time to
digest this the ERG will meeting be
meeting again tomorrow in this room at
the same time once people have had an
opportunity to digest all this
documentation and some of it is pretty
heavy legalese but I've tried to
summarize it for you we as a group will
discuss what attitude if any to take and
we'll be having that meeting just before
PM's queues and we're meeting at half
past 10. and then immediately before the
vote so that is when we as a group will
decide what we're going to do when to be
fed on people have had a chance to plow
through some fairly complex
documentation so can we just take from
that you may actually you may have
should have stayed you may not well the
group hasn't taken the decision yet and
ultimately this has always been our way
it will be down to every individual
colleague in the group so I'm not going
to preempt that decision for all the
reasons I've just given you but now can
I just make a point about the Stormont
the so-called storm on break
you've got a diagram on the back let me
see if I can summarize this for you very
quickly
one it only applies if Stormont is up
and running
so I for instance Shin Fein for a reason
were to just were to collapse the
assembly the brake would no longer apply
secondly it's very limited in its scope
it applies to Goods
but not to stay paid vat the majority of
the Customs code so-called trade defense
measures and the electricity market so
it's only applicable in narrow
circumstances
three
the EU law being proposed against which
the break could be theoretically
deployed has to have a significant
impact on everyday life in Northern
Ireland in a way which is liable to
persist
also it can only
be exercised in exceptional
circumstances
but the Secretary of State for Northern
Ireland
can decide not to accept the break being
used
in exceptional circumstances
it has to be discussed in the UK EU
joint committee as a matter of urgency
where the UK can decide not to implement
the growth
even if they do decide to implement the
break via the Joint Committee the EU can
then still object to that
and the matter is then referred
to arbitration
where the UK could lose
so that is clearly not a veto a veto
means you want to do something and I can
stop you
this is not a veto which is how it has
been characterized for the past three
weeks
even if after all of that
you win a arbitration and there's no
guarantee you will
the EU can then Implement remedial
measures I.E they can retaliate
and then lastly
after all of that if you've had the
temerity to pull the break
the UK via the Joint Committee then has
to produce the results of an urgent
review as to why they felt the break had
to be used in the first place
that is the Stormont break that's
actually sorry
I'm going to leave that to others to
judge but I want people to read this
document which explains all of this in
detail but that is why having explained
it to you I hope having walked you
through it and thank you for your
patience just a second and thank you for
your patience because that is why
we have said that the break is
practically useless against it let's
have wait till we've got our meeting
tomorrow
let's wait to what happens tomorrow
thank you very much indeed for your
attention then Jenna it's all I hope the
press release helps you it's all on the
internet please promulgate it as widely
as you can thank you very much